لقد كنت غاضبًا ، كنت متأكدًا من أنها كانت نوعًا من
عملية احتيال في سبتمبر الماضي ، ساهم شقيق روس
بلات بمبلغ 500 دولار في الحملة الرابحة في
غضون شهر كان ستايسي بلات يرتد
الشيكات التي استنفد حسابه المصرفي ،
رأينا عمليات السحب الستة
البالغة خمسمائة دولار بإجمالي ثلاثة
آلاف دولار
التي تم أخذها من حسابه أه
ابتداءً من منتصف سبتمبر وعلى مدار
شهر استغرقوا ثلاثة آلاف دولار
وأصبح روس توكيلًا ماليًا
لأخيه بسبب تدهور
صحة أخيه ، أدرك بلاتز عندها فقط أن
التوقيع تم التوقيع عليه  لتقديم تبرعات متكررة
إلى حملة ترامب ،
مات بلاك بسبب السرطان في فبراير
،
استمروا في أخذ الأموال إلى أن لم يتبق أي
أموال ولم تكن ستيسي وحدها في
تحقيق في نيويورك تايمز يكشف
عن المدى المقلق في متناول خطة
حملة رابحة محسوبة
لجعل المؤيدين
يشتركون في التبرعات المتكررة بشكل افتراضي
ثم إضافة خانة الاختيار المسبق الثانية
لمضاعفة المتبرعين لاحقًا '  إسهامها
وفقًا للأوقات
التي وصفتها فيها الحملة الرابحة داخليًا بأنها قنبلة مالية ،
وهو تكتيك يقول الخبراء إنه
مصمم عن قصد
ليتم التغاضي عنه بسهولة عندما
يساهم المؤيدون عبر الإنترنت في صندوق أصفر لتقديم
تبرع متكرر ، وقد تم التحقق مسبقًا من
المتبرعين الذين يريدون تقديم تبرع متكرر.
مساهمة لمرة واحدة
لإلغاء الاشتراك ولم يكن من السهل اكتشاف
أنه لم يتذكر رؤية أي شيء من
هذا القبيل كان يعتقد أنه كان يقدم تبرعًا لمرة واحدة بقيمة
500 تبرع بدا أنه كان
مخادعًا
تغاضى عنه الآلاف وتنافست الحملة الرابحة
في الخريف أو أواخر الصيف عندما
واجهت حملة ترامب ضغوطًا مالية ،
قاموا بإجراء تغيير مهم حقًا
وهو أخذ هذا الصندوق بدلاً من
سحب التبرعات كل شهر
بدأوا في إخراجها كل أسبوع
تغمر البنوك وشركات بطاقات الائتمان  مكالمات من المانحين
تقارير الأوقات التي
تقود الحملة الرابحة و rnc
لاسترداد مبلغ ضخم من
المال في نيويورك تايمز الإبلاغ عن ذلك من
خلال الفترة من منتصف أكتوبر وحتى
ديسمبر من عام 2020 ، قامت الحملة الرابحة والمجلس
الوطني الانتقالي برد
أكثر من 530 ألفًا من المبالغ المستردة
بلغت أكثر من 64 مليون
دولار مقارنة بحملة
المناقصات وأعادت dnc 37000 تبرعًا
بلغت 5.6 مليون
قدمناها بشكل جيد للغاية.  أشياء جمع التبرعات ،
ولكن الكثير منها جاء في شكل تبرعات صغيرة ، وجاءت
زيادة الأموال التي جاءت مع
التبرعات المتكررة عندما
كان الرئيس ترامب في حاجة إليها
قبل أسابيع قليلة من الانتخابات وكان يعاني من نقص
في السيولة ،
وبالتالي فإن الأموال التي أخذوها من المتبرعين
من خلال التبرعات المتكررة
تضيف فعليًا وظيفيًا إلى كونها قرضًا واقعيًا
بدون فائدة من
مؤيديها
ولا يتم استردادها إلا بعد الانتخابات
بأموال تم جمعها للحملة
للترويج لمزاعم لا أساس لها
من تزوير الانتخابات ويستخدم الديمقراطيون
هذه الأنواع نفسها من البرامج ولكن ليس من أجل
مدى الطريقة التي
أدارت بها حملة ترامب هذا
الأمر الذي دفعه الرئيس السابق ترامب
إلى التراجع عن تقرير نيويورك تايمز
في إحدى الصحف.  يقول atement إن
جميع جهود جمع التبرعات تمت بشكل قانوني
، ويضيف اقتباسًا أن العديد من الأشخاص كانوا
متحمسين جدًا لدرجة أنهم قدموا
مرارًا وتكرارًا وفي بعض الحالات التي
قدموا فيها الكثير ،
سنقوم على الفور برد
مساهماتهم إلى معدل النزاع الإجمالي
الذي يقول إنه كان أقل من  واحد في المائة من
إجمالي التبرعات عبر الإنترنت مضيفًا جايك
وهو يقول عددًا منخفضًا